hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well all of you having
a professional your study or you know
you may have actually acquired some
along the way you may have several
little things that you've done some
skills you've mastered and those are
part of you right and those are all
structured by the activity which leads
to certain goods and some of those are
goods for you
some of those are goods for other people
and each profession has certain
determinate goods that you don't expect
from all their professions necessarily
so you know let's take some really
trivial examples that that air something
something saddlemaker what is the good
of a saddle maker making saddles
that's that simple yeah what is the good
a flute player what do they make music
and if they're a bad flute player they
they don't make good music and if
they're a good flute player they make
good music right that's their function
he would say so every profession has
some sort of function
what's the purpose of a waiter or a
server in a restaurant do they have more
than one maybe what do you think what
are you looking for when you go into a
restaurant from your your server what
determines whether you're gonna give
them a tip or not or a good tip okay so
that's yeah they don't hang around the
kitchen all day long you know they
actually and why does it matter whether
they're quick or not what's the good
that's coming from that yeah you
actually you get in at a reasonable time
and you get out at a reasonable time and
your food why is it important that you
get your food fast so it's not cold when
you get so it's actually tasty good food
that's one of the things that Oh though
does the waiter themselves provide the
good food no the cook does that right
and there may be a whole chain of people
if you're in a fancy restaurant involved
in the production of that is there
anything else the way they're supposed
to do anything else that would like turn
you off enough that you wouldn't give
them a tip if they didn't do what's up
yeah they're actually supposed to make
you feel like you're in a place you'd
like to be so if they treat you like a
jerk or like you don't matter or
something like that they're not
fulfilling their function well there is
a definite good that they are supposed
to be attaining Aristotle brought into
this question and he says what about you
as a person what about you as a human
being is it the case that flute players
and barrel makers and pick whatever else
you like did they only have some sort of
function or purpose but a human being
himself him or herself no well some
people think that some people think
there is no purpose to human being
overall Aristotle isn't one of those
he thinks there actually is a purpose to
us and he calls this you know sort of
the general good that we are trying to
pursue so he says what could this
function be okay well let's think about
what makes up a human being what are the
most basic at 1-1 sectors what are the
most basic things that you do well
natural order means a lot of different
things in there so Oh in this book he's
taught when he's talking about the
universal good as Plato thought of it
Aristotle doesn't think there is no such
thing he thinks there's a lot of
different types of goods and then
there's like a more overarching good
within within given people's life which
has to do with their their function he
also does talk about another kind of
good that's important a common good
right if we're all here in one community
there is not just the good for me the
good for you the good for her there is a
common good that belongs to all of us if
the classroom okay yeah
universal was tripping them because
play-doh things in all sort of terms now
with the human being so what is it that
we do well it's sort of a really basic
level what we share in common with
plants for all living things are there
are certain things that if you don't do
all bets are off
yeah you better you know breathe and
take in nutrients and get rid of waste
and drink water and and and what else
you know anything else that that fits
into that grow plants grow we grow your
bodies constantly like growing new new
bits because all the old ones are slowly
dying off so he calls this the
vegetative function and let's lay this
out like like you know
the human being so we have we have these
vegetative activities right you don't
actually have to be you know working at
full capacity to do these I mean you
could actually just have a brain stem
and do these a lot of them right that
happens to some people through brain
injuries or birth defects what else
there's one thing plants don't really do
there are several things plants don't
they do that the animals do what
differentiates animals from plants yeah
although you know of course there are
like venus flytraps that's not like that
but let's yeah let's ignore those sort
of exceptions and we eat which means we
actually like go from place to place and
consume food some of the animals just
like sit there and food comes into their
their whatever mouth or whatever yeah
but most animals actually like go
somewhere to get something so there's
there's also locomotion moving from
place to place reading the same ah yes
that's that's very well now some people
think that plants have feelings
aristotle doesn't doesn't want me to
think plants have feelings
some people talk to their plants and you
know i want you to grow i want to
surround your others what's up that's
sunflowers well they they turn to the
Sun I don't know that sunflowers respond
to you saying nice things
well you're right that oh you mean this
far as locomotion
yeah plants have limits of locomotion we
can we can say that animals move a bit
more at least most animals right and the
animals have all sorts of feelings and
desires that's an important part of what
we are that's that's really big and we
share that in common with the animals do
we have exactly the same desires as the
animals there's something cats do that I
just don't understand probably never
will because I'm not a cat but most of
their desires I think we can relate to
fairly easily
can't wait it's interesting we can we
can you can tell whether somebody
whether there's something a bit walk
with them with by looking at whether
they can understand the behavior of the
animals or not those who are like
totally disconnected from the animals
generally those sort of people lack
empathy they're unable to relate to
other people quite as well now you can
go too far and you can like pretend I
cants a person that's sort of thing
Harris I'm going to go for that right
because what does it take to be a person
well let's you says we have this vital
activity right that comes from from
plants and then we have sentient life
being able to sense things to move from
place to place to eat to feel to have
desires for things and then he says
there's the practical life of the
rational part death so that we have this
Rancho
so here here we're doing something
that's a little bit different than the
animals that's worth the asking how are
we different than other animals because
we're animals there's there's no you
know two ways about that we eat we move
from place to place we do desire we
procreate what else do we do the animals
do you know build things that animals
build things a bit you know fight with
each other yeah that pretty much covers
the gamut doesn't it what what is this
other part of us that's different than
what makes us distinctively good yeah
yeah you know animals do think to some
degree all right I mean if you can you
can take a cat and if it's sufficiently
motivating you can get it to do some
problem solving I actually had a cat
that you know I tried really hard and if
it had thumbs it would have let itself
up it figured out that the door handle
had to be turned and it would get up
there and fourth thing and try to you
know use its paws and they would get
very frustrated but it couldn't figure
that out but we do it at a much higher
level dolly
yeah we're gonna say that's very
important animals do communicate with
each other
Aristotle in the politics says animals
communicate with each other and they
talk to themselves about you know
painful and the pleasurable for example
but the animals don't communicate about
the good and the bad or the just and the
unjust they don't ask themselves
questions like am i a good dog you do
ask yourself questions like am ia good
person and you also ask more general
questions this goes that higher level of
thinking what is a good person what is a
bad person am i right in my assessments
at that point we're getting way beyond
with the
is capable of I mean it's not just that
the animals don't do linear algebra or
you know create an iPhone's or you know
put things on the internet or things
like that
right or you know manufacture coffee
it's also an important part of our moral
life in which we're different from the
animals in which we have a higher part
of ourselves and Aristotle says that if
we think of the soul there is a non
rational part of the soul which we share
in common with plants and animals which
we have to because we're we're beings in
the world and then there's a rational
part of the soul and he says that part
of this rational part of the soul has
its fully it's can think things out it
can reflect it has principles by which
it operates then there's a part of the
soul which is rational in the sense that
it is as he says obedience to principle
so you can't generate you know
high-level thoughts by itself but it can
follow them they can understand well
yeah I mean Freud didn't didn't start
out without you know any of these other
people being around before him it you
can't you can't strictly identify plate
over Aristotle's ideas about the parts
of the soil with no ego super-ego yeah
you can do it pretty easily with this
ego is a lot harder to fit in for doing
it if you're doing a careful job now
Aristotle notice Aristotle doesn't see
the small way the plate of it Plato had
a three-part
soul right the rational the spirited and
the
Tytos or a desirous part aristotle has
the rational part of soul and the non
rational part of the souls two parts but
each one has its own subdivisions now if
you want to know what makes a human
being a good human being you want to
know what the purpose of human existence
is where do you think you ought to look
I mean you could look just at
professions you're a good human being if
in fact you fulfill the you know social
walls that you have and maybe it's not
necessarily professions maybe we could
tie it in with other kinds of roles but
you know if you're a good dad you're a
good human being you know all it takes
to be a good human being is being a good
you know mom or dad being a good parent
being a good friend being a good lover
you know people identify themselves with
those sorts of things well the
possibility is you look at what human
beings on a common and if you want to
figure out what makes you a good human
being not just what makes you a good
being but a good human being
Aristotle says look at this what is the
function of the you know rational part
of our soul or personality what is its
excellence what is what is working well
for it and this is where he's going to
lead into eventually talking about
virtues what he calls the intellectual
virtues are going to be involved and
we're not going to actually a study
those very much those are involved with
the fully rational part of the soul so
for example practical wisdom that has to
do with the highest part of your being
science or you know disciplinary
knowledge or a craft skill the sort of
thing that you're studying in your major
you're actually developing the highest
part of your soul if you're doing it
right if you're studying social work or
business or fashion merchandising or or
were some of the other majors in here is
there any social sociology majors
sike special ad actually that's an
interesting one because you're actually
education is thinking about our thinking
in all sorts of high-level ways right
all of these are actually developing the
highest part of your soul that's why
maybe doing your profession could have
something to do with this but this goes
beyond just your profession
then there's the moral virtues and those
are concerned not just with the very
highest part of your soul that's
involved there but with this this part
of your soul that's rational and that it
can obey reason it can be structured by
reason it can recognize that reason a
lot to rule it and this is where
feelings come in in part because the
feelings that we have are not just
purely animal we go beyond the animals
in important ways animals feel feelings
right your dog or cat loves you it does
love you
it doesn't just see you as a food
dispenser and pet dispenser right if you
can't hate you on the other hand you
can't really hate you the genuine
feelings but feelings for us are more
complex you might say we feel feelings
more richly more deeply in ways that can
get us in more trouble but in ways that
can also elevate us yeah a lot of what's
going to make us good is going to depend
not just on what we do for Aristotle but
on what we feel and why we feel it the
emotional response that we have as well
as the action response that we have
we're going to talk much more about that
later on about the particulars of that
but I just wanted to you know have you
have you see this now what's going to
constitute you know good functioning or
what he calls flourishing is going to be
what we are translating here is a
happiness so this is a good place to
transition now to happiness when this
part of the soul is fulfilling its
function well you will be happy and you
probably will also have a role in making
other people happy when this part of the
soul is screwed up you will be in some
way cut walk from happiness you will be
not able to participate in that fully or
even to glimpse it correctly and if you
make certain basic mistakes about the
nature of the human being or about what
actually will make us happy and how to
value these things
or even about your profession you will
be cutting yourself off from the
possibility of full genuine happiness
what makes our life truly worth living
according to Aristotle